good morning John I know that we said
maybe we weren't going to do videos this
week but hey I found something that I
really wanted to share with you and it
is this lid to a tea it's a tea lid from
a Boba place and it's specifically a tea
lid that you can use for Boba so I guess
you can do hot Boba and you would put
the Boba straw through this part of the
teal and then you got your normal
sipping hole here this is the hy90m5 if
you want to look it up and there's
something very odd about this tea lid
and I want to know what's going on and I
can't figure out the answer and so I'm
turning to the power that I have and
should not abuse in this way but please
someone to help me figure out what's
going on if you take a look at the hy90
M5 can we get a focus you will see that
it says heat 110 degrees Celsius that to
me is very weird on its own but then
also notice that the one and the one are
different fonts I'm gonna talk through
why I think this is so strange for the
hy90m5 to say heat one one zero degrees
Celsius and have the ones be in two
different fonts first of all tea is made
out of liquid water and liquid water
cannot get hotter than 100 degrees
Celsius so you cannot heat tea hotter
than 100 degrees Celsius unless you're
changing the pressure unless you are
putting it in a pressure vessel and
putting a bunch of extra air molecules
in there you cannot heat to above 100
degrees Celsius you especially cannot do
that in Montana where we're way above
sea level but that's not part of the
conversation the only thing that makes
sense that it means to me is that this
beverage is hot like you wanted to
re-emphasize the part where it says
caution hot across the top you wanted to
reemphasize that with the heat of the
drink in here is 110 degrees Celsius
which to an American does not sound very
hot so that's a problem but I understand
this lid is not necessarily made for an
American audience because it's a bobolin
and we haven't been on the Boba train
for that long and we certainly haven't
been on the hot Boba train for very long
I have of course looked this up it's a
lid from Taiwan where they use celsius
so the only thing that makes sense is
that they put heat 110 degrees Celsius
just to re-emphasize that this is very
hot it's hotter than you think it is
it's hotter than boiling water even
though that is literally impossible
unless it contains pure steam so I want
to tell you the incorrect thing that I
thought about this I thought that it
said heat 110 degrees Celsius because
originally it said heat 100 degrees
Celsius and then somebody decided to
take off one of the zeros and add a one
just to totally emphasize that this is
hotter than boiling water even though
that's not possible then it can't it
isn't it isn't but they wanted people to
be safe so they added an extra 10
degrees Celsius to an already impossible
temperature and when they did that they
used a different phone they didn't have
access to the original document they had
to cut and paste to make it look like it
said 110 degrees Celsius in fact if you
look very close the bottom of this one
is a little bit higher than the bottom
of this one so it's definitely Photoshop
and the only reason to do that is if you
want to make get more clear that this is
very hot liquid but I wanted to confirm
this so I went on the internet and I
looked up the hy90 M5 and John it used
to say 120 degrees Celsius
it used to say 120 degrees Celsius and
they changed it to a lower temperature I
assume because some patent like me was
like there isn't a way that the t is 120
degrees Celsius it would just be steam
it would be gaseous water it would
explode and so
they lowered it
to an also impossible temperature like
somebody did that making sure that extra
work was done so that no one would be
happy if anybody has any theories about
how this happened that more accurately
explains the given circumstances in ways
that are less infuriating please let me
know John I hope you're having a
wonderful New Year's and I'll see you in
2023